the list of people who continue to
insist that Robert molars report can be
accurately summarized as no collusion no
obstruction is getting smaller and
smaller
even though Trump's hard core base still
believes it and even Fox News host Bret
Baier who just a few weeks ago tried to
tag-team Bernie Sanders during that Fox
News Town Hall along with the other
moderator Martha McCallum even that bret
bayer now admits when muller spoke
yesterday he didn't say no collusion no
obstruction now this is small it's a
small win but every time somebody on the
right wing echo chambers a list of
characters tells an even uncontroversial
truth about the molar probe it's a good
thing it's another attempt to pierce
that echo chamber in which a lot of
these right-wingers are living Bret
Baier yesterday right after Robert
Muller gave his statement during which
he said if we could have cleared Trump
we would have cleared Trump but we
didn't Bret Baier appeared on Fox News
to provide analysis as they call it and
he said this is much more than no
collusion no obstruction check it out
from a are standing by anchor a special
report Bret your takeaway from all that
Robert Muller resigning and returning to
private life and he said a lot there he
did he also said he is not planning on
testifying and Bill's right there could
be a subpoena that compels him to but
he's making the choice not to I was
struck by the tone and tenor of those
remarks as he laid out his his case
wrapping up this report this was not as
the president says time and time again
no collusion no obstruction it was much
more nuanced than that he said
specifically they couldn't find evidence
sufficient to move forward with a crime
on the issue of conspiracy on the
collusion part of the investigation of
the Trump campaign he said specifically
if they had found that the president did
not commit a crime on obstruction they
would have said that and then went into
specific details so you might react to
this by saying who cares what
Fox News clown bret baier says well the
reason we care is because the Fox News
crowd is significantly clueless about
this reality it matters that Bret Bayer
says this is not no collusion no
obstruction because a lot of the core
Fox News audience has been living under
the belief of no collusion no
obstruction
ever since the bar letter came out and
Donald Trump went on a nationwide no
collusion no obstruction victory tour
they are watching Fox News not because
it informs them but because it makes
them feel good because it sort of
confirms their preconceived notions it
confirms what they want to be true which
makes them feel good and it actually
goes even further because for some
people Fox News confirms their biases
for other people people who were even
less informed Fox News is actually
setting the biases which works and it
even works on Trump Fox News sometimes
sets Trump's position and point of view
on different issues and that's why it
matters that Brett Maher says this and
what you have to understand about Fox is
that it is a business that makes money
from right-wing news and commentary if
Donald Trump ultimately turns on Fox
News or if Fox News believes that is
just no longer profitable to be the
Trump channel they'll stop I mean
they'll still be right-wing but they can
separate from Trump at any time there
are many shades of right-wing propaganda
there can be conservative propaganda
there's statist authoritarian propaganda
which is sort of de facto right-wing
there's trumpian propaganda of course
there's anti democratic party propaganda
not all right wing propaganda assumes
this sort of endless unwavering support
of Donald Trump I don't actually expect
the change anytime soon but the point is
Fox News is propaganda is carefully
calculated for profit and what's
profitable for them could change over
time and if it does they will abandon
Donald Trump they won't abandon the
right wing but they will abandon Donald
Trump